okay so now we have some
points here let's list them out shall we
okay
um i'll put them down here because each
of these pairs of numbers
gives us some coordinates right so this
first one here
that's negative two four okay
then you've got this one here that's
negative one
one what's this one here this is a
special one it's the origin good
zero zero okay and then you can keep on
reading off right
so let's draw this thing
let's draw it draw yourself up a set of
axes maybe make it a bit bigger than
these ones because we want some detail
here
okay and we'll draw this in yeah yeah
quickly
actually now can you can you first
before you do can you maybe draw this
and then go
yeah so draw fast
too much information okay
yeah yeah they would say well i guess i
think the proper wording would be
sketch the graph of y equals x squared
right so y equals x squared is like one
of these guys it's an equation it's a
rule
so here's the thing they're looking for
all of them
together i'll show you what i mean all
right so
these five points i'm going to plot all
of them on here
okay try and make your um scale
reasonable here so
minus two let's put some markings on
here
okay so label them on okay so
-2 that's over here and then you go up
four right
one two three four there
minus one one where's that going to be
it'll be it'll be just in here won't it
there's minus one
one two three four five okay so
there it is are you already following
that yeah yeah
i'm doing these points i'm taking them
and i'm putting them on yeah
zero zero we already established is
right there at the origin okay
and then now hold on a second you know
how we said oh it's like a palindrome
right we have um we have maths language
we have
geometric language that describes these
kinds of things
we would say for instance you know if i
showed you a triangle
right or a rectangle that was the same
one way as it is the other you wouldn't
say oh that's a palindromic
triangle you'd say it's a symmetric
symmetrical triangle right
so we're gonna observe the same thing
here watch this one one where's that
it's here right and then
sorry that should be a two two four
one two one two three four
it's up there okay now yeah you can see
if i join up these dots
right i've got this symmetry to it it's
the same way
one way as the end right so now put your
pins down for a second
which means dance for a second when i
look at these one two three four
five dots right i could join them up
like this
right because you're like the way we've
joined them up before you do this right
uh from there to there
and then from there to there and then
then
there and up to bit okay
but um and that looks well it looks sort
of convincing
but something seems wrong about it right
because it's kind of like oh i'm kind of
changing
course and then i'm it's like it's like
an awkward sort of um
dot-to-dot type thing right it's not
doing that and you can check it
by taking smaller values like what if i
said what about a half
where would that be or what about one
and a half or as we kept going like
three four five six seven
in fact the pattern is not these
straight lines the pattern
is a curved line
like that
okay mine's not that great but you can
see the idea
right and the important thing is that
it's all
curved all the way right so whereas
these guys are all
linear they're all straight lines okay
we have left straight lines and we
didn't it didn't take much to lose
straight lines right
we only modified it just a little bit
while you're staring at this well let's
give the whale a name
this particular kind of whale is called
a
problem that's the name of this shape
okay so
hi parabola the blue whale get it
because blue anyway
um that's the whole shape
and there's an important part of it
which is two point
this point down here right at the origin
in this case right
can you see it's a little bit like this
shape coming down and it turns around
right it comes down and then it goes up
so it turns right
it's a bit like a car turning around
right so we call that point
we call it we call it a turning point
because it's the point
where it turns okay yeah um if you like
you kept going with that xy
table thing yep say like a thousand
times would the line just keep
coding outwards or well okay so that's a
very good question
what happens as we keep going further
and further away
now the reason why i haven't done more
values is because well you told me right
the next number would be 9
and then 16 and then 25 36
by the time you get to 10 you're already
up at 100. i can't i can't draw anymore
running out of space
so it's going to keep getting see how
it's like really shallow here
and then it gets steeper the steeper
so in other words this is a really
important idea
see with these the grain of the lines
always the same
right look same steepness same steepness
this is also the same statement this is
steeper but it's still
the same all the way but this beast is
different
right at this point the gradient is
going down
so it should be negative right it's
going down
over here it's going up and it's going
faster and faster
negative's decreasing
and it's going
yeah so this is decreasing but can you
see
this part here right it looks more like
this
then it looks like this these guys are
climbing up the hill
and this guy is rolling down okay
so here the point the point is that it's
it's changing
the gradient keeps changing and that's
kind of weird
okay by the way um tony point is another
name for it um the latin
for turning hat is the word um verteir
or something like that so this is often
called the vertex
just means turning point